so I know what I'm supposed to do up
here I'm supposed to have an acceptance
speech and thank a long list of people
that probably never you remember five
minutes after the speech is over and to
be honest I'm horrible at acceptance
speeches and there's a youtube video
that proves that so I'm gonna do what I
know how to do best I'm gonna tell a
story fourteen years ago I was a
firefighter and I was at the fire
station and I love my job and I loved I
was doing and I was watching the news
and I saw two planes crash into the Twin
Towers and my whole world turned upside
down and everything that I thought I had
knew made no sense to me and all the
questions that I had about the world and
about where I was was not getting
answered by mainstream media so about
six months after 9/11 I traveled to
Afghanistan to answer those questions
for myself I was in a village in
Afghanistan have about 200 people and
this family who didn't know me took me
in fed me and clothed me and treated me
as one of their own and we were walking
in the market and I was with the
grandfather of the family and across
this local market there was another man
who was yelling and screaming at me and
posh tune and although I didn't know
what he was saying I knew that he didn't
like me and he didn't want me there
the grandfather that I was with ran over
and grabbed the man by his collar and
lifted them in the air and said
something very very mean in Pashto and
after the other man turned to me and
said sorry in Pashto and welcome to
Afghanistan in English what this story
taught me is that I knew nothing about
the world and that at that age and even
now I'm humbled by my ignorance and so
that kind of started my journey to
become a documentary filmmaker because I
didn't really want to save the world I
just wanted to understand
and from that day on I knew that there
was so many questions out there and so
many stories that weren't told that I
felt an obligation to tell them and this
was one of them and I wanted to dedicate
this to two very special people in my
life who put up with my [ __ ] and loved
me unconditionally to my father who's
let me run feral and free for all these
years
sorry about that Dad and to my mother
who taught me how to be a badass woman
thank you